hey theo hey brandon um this is like my
80s
trying to make this video because i'm so
nervous and i'm really sorry if it's
shaky camera work but i
am from the west coast canada and i have
a king and her singer for you
um eating a lot on the first date should
you just be play and have the salad or
is it okay cool with the burger
fries milkshake all that um i personally
am a burgers girl but yeah i can't
understand it
eating a lot on the first date buzz buzz
hey first of all she was talking very
fast like she's being held
i do want to say that she didn't have a
lot of time it looks yeah yeah
yeah she's all buzz buzz she's like
really quickly uh
yes uh yeah uh kidnapping people in uh
[Laughter]
this is me shooting my shot isn't
shooting my shot for the police
i'm sorry we're just joking young lady
you seem like a beautiful young lady
yeah she's very attractive yeah well
brendan
there's a lot more to her than that dude
she obviously wants to know
she she's like being held hostage like
britney spears people think britney
spears has been trying to signal her
fans
through her instagram videos her dad has
all her rights yeah like power of
attorney or something she can't make any
decisions and some fans will be like
we're yellow
and then the next video should be in all
yellow then like show a picture with
pigeons if you're
you know if you're in trouble and just
show pictures with a bunch of pigeons
like she's literally listening
hey y'all her freaking videos are
freaking absolutely ridiculous
it's so crazy okay dude it's very random
have you seen the other stuff supposed
to commit to this like there's something
going on there
dude what do we know about women we
don't know [ __ ] that's fair yeah
but you might be right though man you
might be right i'm sorry dude there's
like that's in this head
into it see i can't put my head in it
but what did this this girl want to know
eating on the first date do you just
have a little side salad you go for that
[ __ ] balls deep
i have the side salad you have a side
salad yeah
i i like something that i can uh knife
and fork oh really i show them that i'm
fancy oh show them your handy like you
don't first date no no chicken wings
ribs oh you did done well in that class
i was in then yeah
i took that class you did yeah
uh you can't you can't do messy stuff
probably no spaghetti no pastas
no crawfish no crawfish yeah new
crawfish
for me no broccoli i don't know in
louisiana you could take a girl to a
crawfish boil as like a first date maybe
i think it gets messy though dude
yeah that's true still sexual though too
it is a little bit get that full rack of
rib you start
showing her you suck that rib bruh or
you get you're playing you put crawfish
and her plate is just like
seven things of corn and she's like what
do i have all these
what i've just long corn the ears of the
corn
and she's sucking on the head yeah yeah
the second on the head yeah i think
there's a lot
bite the tail suck the head maybe it's
the second date you go for crawfish
yeah i know what's a good date where
it's a good date
spot man for dinner well chin's place
that he always goes exactly the best
oh korean barbecue's not bad it's pretty
damn good you cook for him too
yeah so it's sweet yeah yeah yeah it's
kind of annoying but
[Laughter]
take it easy it's not the 50s but if you
bring your own meat in there sometimes i
like to do that for korean barbecue i'll
sneak a cut to my own meat
you know i'll toss some [ __ ] grapes
on that [ __ ] grill i'll sneak a
little bit of half of a swan neck or
something i know myself
somebody's exotic i'll put some [ __ ]
ostrich on that [ __ ] do a turkey neck
or half a strip
penguin [ __ ] boom yeah it is nice when
you bring some of your own [ __ ] and
people look over and you got it damn
you had a zebra rib hoe oh big old rib
on there
yeah yeah dude you got a [ __ ] yeah
you got a little bit of a leopard hip
over there
like get that elephant trunk on the
grill bro you eat that endangered
species
now chin have you taken some first dates
to this type of place where you got this
disease at
[Laughter]
got the disease out yeah
what whatever let's this is a two-parter
first of all
yeah go for it where do you think you
got the disease at that you have
what do i think let's see let's
backtrack okay
i'm guessing when i don't know if i had
to put money on this
i would say possibly through brendan
o'brien whoa whoa whoa guy
what are you talking about what where's
your proof
there's no proof there's no way playing
gravity there's really no way to trap
with [ __ ] korean barbecue every other
goddamn day
that's true you were out in a lake that
thousands of other people have been in
this year
a boat yeah that's true but i was with
my girlfriend she's pretty clean
does she have it no she's good she's
healthy how does she not have it then
she might be asymptomatic the last time
i saw was a weekend before
and then the monday that i worked i
didn't see her after that so
and have you heard from her or seen her
at all is she all right talk to her
everyday oh okay that's
good face down here she's good she's
great but what was your question
has he taken girls on dates at korean
bbq that's all he does that's his move
no and also the best i think the best
one is sushi
ooh sushi a little here here's the thing
it's not
sex it is here's the thing if you if you
want some problems
and it happens with sushi you eat sushi
that went bad that dates
game set match true if you go to a bad
place oh you're blowing up the toilet
son but who's eating
bad who's eating what happens at the
best of best places sometimes it's just
a little tuna that's been out a little
too long
no it does and i think you know that as
a human species if you're supposed to be
alive
and you want and god wants you to be
alive for a long time
then you don't eat bad food that's going
to kill you because you know in your own
brain what's going on sometimes too late
you swallow that eel roll
a little funky sauce on there that's
seen that you know your stomach's going
hey dog
date's over damn that's why you got to
stick with chef pal's sauce man
bring your own sausage cream barbecue
might be the best idea for a first date
korean barbecue feed each other too what
do you think cat let's say you get a
female perspective they pump the break
just say
chin over here what you cook for them
feed each other
drink dude culture bro don't deny him
his culture man
i don't think so he will kill himself in
a puddle for his wife
what have you seen those videos where
they die and then he's like walking
across my back
to get your shoes wet no yeah what are
you saying cat they do that [ __ ] dude if
he was a girl his dad would have killed
him
wait what i have no idea what's going on
you know what i'm talking about jen no
yeah you do all right well you're saying
oh cat what's your good first date
um korean barbecue i also like it if a
guy can cook if he cooks for me on the
first date i'm very impressed
hold on you gotta go to the crib and he
cooks for you that's yes
that's a little that's a little mud like
yeah first thing if you're like hey
if let's say somebody's asking for a
date you're like oh where are we going
he's like my crib
it's like jesus and what if you what if
he he goes to the bathroom or something
he
comes out and catches you looking
through his stuff why am i looking
through his stuff why wouldn't you
yeah why wouldn't you yeah
i feel like girls are smarter where if
we wanted to snoop we would snoop
through your bathroom
yeah because then you can't just come in
you're not just walking into the
bathroom
but if you're in there for too long i'll
be like oh she took a [ __ ] in my
bathroom
which is fine that's that's a human
thing yeah people [ __ ] all the time
everything's [ __ ] have you been to a pet
store before everything in their shits
yeah yeah that's fair uh besides just
cooking at home where else cat
i i like italian food okay it gets messy
though
but the light you get a big sloppy
lasagna dude
she's not taking him to [ __ ] sbarros
dude
it's like a decent place
that pizza [ __ ] better than a little
cardboard covered in lettuce
that [ __ ] is terrible dude whatever man
you guys don't know anything tomorrow's
is [ __ ]
you gotta get out more dude it's
regional it's nice it's the i mean
people like it
what about uh so yeah i think if you
have a place you could grill something
do you think you take somebody to a
family event or something like that on a
first date
really see that's the kind of [ __ ] i do
that's why i'm laughing that's so cheap
what was your first date he took me his
family
bro i'm reunion joking i just now
remember there was this really sweet
girl
from slaughter louisiana she came to my
brother's house for
dinner one time uh and she it was my
family dude and i hadn't even seen half
my family in like a year yeah so you
putting cats
up she's all over in the corner and my
brother and then we just moved in this
house and they had a real small table
so we all had to eat like really close
to each other
and the food was not good it was so old
and my brother's kids were lit like just
newborn
just chaos chaos throwing [ __ ]
and it was just like who was this girl
i don't know yeah well we'll know
i said i don't know but i'll you know
i'm trying to see how she handles the
pressure yeah let's put her right
that's funny let's put her right into
that deep oven where chin
is right now that's why i knew when he
asked that some deal [ __ ]
it makes me feel bad too why i do that
kind of stuff you know oh yeah
come to my look a buddy of mine passed
away
one of my best friends has a funeral
today why don't we go to that tonight
pretty dope wake let's go do it you know
wear some wake sexy you know
dress kind of death sexy let's do it man
is